[Music]
I'm not an enforcer I'm more like a um a
fixer
exactly I have to convince a certain
person that the body in that trunk out
there is indeed Rolo something happened
to his
face what the it's Miss along with the
rest of his
head betrayal is a funny thing it's very
nature is to catch you
unaware you ever heard a ring doorbell
we're under attack
go St
gone and you should be too I've always
heard one Ru shall be good to the people
who were good to you be good to yourself
Charlie and get as far away from here as
you
can you turned on your own he want to
get out of buuy char that's what
everyone keeps telling
me that 50 Grand could really change
things for me I'm going with it without
[Music]
you ask Charlie I got more men than you
got bullets bullets are easy to
get what do you want you not breathing
and how you going to do that I'm doing
it will
you you know you really ought to start
thinking about an Exit Plan what are you
waiting
for pull the trigger
[Music]
Charlie you're in over your
head I don't like loose
hands he was my second best guy I'm
looking forward to meeting number
one for a long
[Music]
time